[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge ein hof am
sie silvia und marcus burg suchen die
ruhe in schweden sie wollen dort
ferienwohnungen vermieten wie warme corp
stephan aurand dion stefano navarrete
zieht es in die karibik im land ist der
kieler wittern sie ihre chance und
familie zogaj möchte sich in südafrika
neu erfinden
ihr traum eine eigene lodz
sid
[Musik]
silvia und marcus burg müssen in die
frauenklinik zur kontrolle
silvia ist im sechsten monat schwanger
es soll ihr letzter arztbesuch in der
schweiz sein bevor es nach schweden geht
[Musik]
ausgerechnet in dem moment als sie den
termin für die auswanderung festlegten
wo der see wieder schwanger also nach
dem was mir erlebt dann wissen wir dass
kinder keine selbstverständlichkeit sind
und das genieße mir jetzt genießen was
halten unser traumland gehäuse so 22
große ereignis mit dem er mit freude
entgegen nehme also vor dem herrn ihn
gedanke verschiebe absage
er erstreckt
die ärzte müssen regelmäßig schauen ob
es dem baby gut geht
sevilla hatte bereits drei fehlgeburten
ja ich doch nicht
weniger der puls runter 2
das grund für rund 5 punkten
google
wird die runde mit dem ultraschall zeigt
dr
links wie sich das baby seit der letzten
untersuchung entwickelt hat so
darstellung von vom profi rasen also bei
screen
[Musik]
sich constanze bleibt oder das ist
natürlich schon so unglaublich viel dass
das jetzt die einfachste und römisches
glaubwürdig bei dem schönen stadt
leibnitz von mir sagt das mehr oder
weniger egal ich habe vor das andere ist
zugabe
[Musik]
alles in ordnung aus sicht des arztes
können die drei lose ziehen ins neue
heim nach schweden
[Musik]
am bodensee bei familie zogaj ja schöne
schöne davoser schlitten dings der stadt
kaputt davon aber ja
dabei stützt ja auch für diesen huser
und zustand es war ein hose und jacke
wie viel liter frei mit und wie viel das
war durchaus erwartet unterricht mit der
sorge das haus in steckborn hat die
familie schon verkauft jetzt wurden
talker ist noch überflüssigen hausrat
loswerden bevor sie in südafrika neu
starten
die türkei scannen südafrika doris war
regelmäßig mit ihrem team dort schon als
jugendlicher erlebte er knapp sieben
jahre lang mit seinen eltern am kap
wenn ich mir vorstelle nach italien
dritter der horror dass er auf mich
unvorstellbar england oder und südafrika
schwimm ja klar da weiß man ungefähr
wird schwierigkeiten sind und vor allem
charts zu finden und damit machen
aus dem einfamilienhaus auf die farm bei
kapstadt talkers wollen bald gäste
bewirten und beherbergen
können wir mit genau die studie der oja
wird gar nicht gewalt nur für leute die
leidringer hätte beine hat hochstuhl
paul sommer also wenn eine unserer
studie wollten gerne aber so schnell und
wie viel wäre man seinen 200
der siebenjährige mika und die
elfjährige annika haben ein paar
spielsachen aussortiert die auswanderer
haben in der lokalzeitung annonciert
ihren freunden und bekannten bescheid
gesagt und die nachbarn informiert ganz
viel war
das garagentor naja die besuch haben
einiges mitgenommen
trotzdem galt nur für südafrika
liestal stefano de und stefano navarrete
sind ein eingespieltes team
beste freunde und geschäftspartner
[Musik]
stefano navarrete hat freitag seinen
festen termin beim papier stefano
lucchini begleitet die ich ja seit ihrer
jugend kennen sich stefano und stefano
zusammen haben die baselbieter eine
personalagentur aufgebaut die firma lief
gut trotzdem zieht es sie weg nach
mexiko wieder so gut um grund
möglichkeit gestoßen werden mit der 14
denn vielleicht die gelegenheit zu
nutzen
weil ich habe geträumt haben als co neue
farbige machen hat sich es soweit ist
kürzlich im land dann sagen wir auch in
mexiko vertraut stefano zunächst auf
einen sicheren job
er steigt als geschäftsführer in der
firma seines onkels ein familienauto
natürlich eine luxusvariante von
wanderern ist die figur immer die
sehnsucht die wünsche sorgen und
irgendwo anders co jetzt setzt auch das
thema weiß ja nie was aber bringt man
sitzen weiter was hätte ich nur gemacht
ohne diese ferrari box mit allem was
hätte ich nur gemacht ist es ist ja gar
nichts schiefgehen minimum 50 prozent
weniger freundlich gehabt und mit ohne
deine barth 50 prozent weniger umsatz
[Gelächter]
außerdem wollen die beiden dort mit
immobilien handeln ihr startkapital ist
das geld das sie mit ihrer
personalagentur gemacht haben aber alle
bitte machen nicht zu schön ich brauche
ihm noch ja nicht dass alle frauen in
mexiko nach
[Musik]
dies wie im bau vieler muss
marcus burg ist gelernter schreiner
schon seit sieben uhr steht er in der
werkstatt
sein auftrag heute türrahmen im akkord
zusammensetzen so dass man die
möglichkeit hat als normalsterbliche
güter leichter die chance in der schweiz
dann einfach nicht und außerdem ich
werde mein schönes land
es ist immer mehr natur verbunden sie
leben um einen millimeter die natur an
dem sind und das heißt dann im winter
wird man gang runtergeschaltet und ich
glaube uns ist es nämlich so wie uns
hier auf weihnachten er nur der gang
höher geschaltet
[Musik]
in schweden wartet ein hof am see auf
die junge familie markus und seine frau
haben diesen entdeckt auf einer ihrer
vielen reisen
[Musik]
jetzt kann markus jede freie minute für
die vorbereitung gebrauchen
nur mit
erzähle tage zweimal demnächst etwas ein
countdown geld muss dann irgendwann
da fange packe und dann los
das klappt davon irgendwann immer wieder
mich sehr gefreut glaubst du nicht
familie irgendwann mal beleidigt
hier haben markus und zebra vor drei
jahren noch gearbeitet
im renovation fachbetrieb von cbs eltern
diese wollten die firma an die
auswanderer übergeben
[Musik]
ich kenne ein paar das geschäft vom
vater übernommen oder so was die die
händler übernehmen weil er selbst mache
und ich weiß sie sind wir glücklich es
gibt ganz viele wo lieber was anderes
machen würde wie der elterliche betrieb
über eine aber es ist halt
es stimmt für uns das ist das wichtige
bei mir in unser leben leben fast vier
jahren am versuchten markus und sylvia
den erwartungen der familie gerecht zu
werden
sevilla leitete er im betrieb die
finanzen den showroom und organisierte
die ausstellungen
markus war geschäftsführer
beide gaben vollgas in ihren shops ich
habe einfach gemerkt vor allem markus
das ist eben nicht gut gegangen ist und
einer im haus haben auch nie zum
heiligen und irgend einmal müsse einfach
gestaltet dass verschiedentlich einfach
nicht aus wie schon erwähnt und die
kronleuchter die wette ich eigentlich
verkaufen muss man der us-bürger zum
fotografieren
das habe ich im kopf und habe mir zwei
mal
[Musik]
diese geschmack hat sich extrem
verändert stellt grafisch in szene
setzen
[Musik]
kaffeemaschinen indirekt programm alles
berater knapp doris spricht in steckborn
auf zu ihrem letzten tag im büro
diamanti bord bleibt mit den kindern zu
hause und ich denke zwischen drei und
halbiert
doris herrmann ist selbständiger it
consultant hat aber bewusst schon länger
keine aufträge mehr angenommen
der 50 jährige kümmert sich vor allem um
ihr projekt in südafrika die form im cup
holländischen stil ist riesig allein der
umschwung ist so groß wie 60
fußballfelder
wir sind durch fahre wir sind
ausgestiegen
wir sind da und wir uns sagt kösters ist
ohne ohne york und irgendwie ist das
anwesen kostet rund 1,1 millionen
franken
hinzu kommt noch die renovation zu viel
für familie zogaj allein mir heute
vertrag unterschrieben mit dem wissen
dass mir ein partner ein für das
unternehmen mit einem investor ist da
wieder käufer und ich mal betonen weil
dieser in letzter minute abgesprungen
hat mit dem projekt uhr sondern sind
wirkliche persönliche sie ja wir sind
natürlich jetzt auf hochtouren
3 irgendwie war der satz zu machen aber
das ist jetzt zum wichtiger punkt
zeitpunkt noch nicht gelöst topf
brauchen dringend einen neuen geldgeber
denn es gibt kein zurück
[Applaus]
doris hat die letzten sieben jahre bei
der kantonspolizei thurgau verarbeitet
in der fachstelle für häusliche gewalt
sie leitete ein team mit vier
mitarbeitern
die ungewisse zukunft braucht kraft
doris hat schon viel gemacht nur der job
war immer sicher als schriften malerin
als sozialarbeiterin im strafvollzug und
bei der jugendanwaltschaft bin ich taxi
vor allem arbeitsbereich und sexy bin da
ist schon viel aber wie mehrere
schweizer besonders für mich stand aber
ich war sichtbar bleibt ist ganz klar so
einiges größte art stelle aber sie haben
ja sogar aus der sicherheit den weg in
die selbständigkeit macht die 45 jährige
zum ersten mal
jorge molina ins regierungsboot stefano
und stefano lösen ihre firma in der
schweiz endgültig auf das
zweifamilienhaus in niederdorf war ein
teil ihres geschäftes
die beiden stephanus haben handwerker
aus dem ausland auf baustellen in der
schweiz vermittelt etliche ihrer
leiharbeiter haben sie hier
untergebracht und das solo und und
renoviert damit ihre geliebten könne
eine unterkunft birte es ist in ganz
spanien ungarn polen überall ein wo
willi gesehen wo in der schweiz weil
erschaffen und die familien eigentlich
so unterstütze über 70 handwerker hatten
die beiden unter vertrag
morgen haben wir die ganze lied fremd
für mitteleuropäer unterkunft und wir
haben nie drauf gehen ja und dann ist
die deko das mit auslauf oder
liegenschaft holen damit mehr an oder
das stück vom kuchen für uns abschnitten
und wenn ich das mit meinem husum bad
und jetzt im nächsten schritt weil
zukünftig in mexiko an dass ich das haus
wollten sie noch sanieren
aber dann haben sie einen interessenten
gefunden der es so übernimmt wie es ist
jetzt hält die beiden nichts mehr in der
schweiz
die personalagentur ist schon verkauft
bis zu ihrem start in mexiko haben sie
sich ein provisorisches büro
eingerichtet
als der fan uwe renners mutter habe sie
eine horde bull fliegen
januar das ist jetzt hostel in kuba wo
man für ein jahr könnten fotos verwalten
und das sind jetzt die heutige burg in
der ruine hoch sind
was vorgestern führt haben wir jetzt
sagte bugar genau das ist super super
trottelig ausrede weil er hat mir das in
frage wo es gar nicht notwendig wäre mir
gesagt du los dass ich jetzt die
möglichkeit die formal unter beweis
stellen bevor durch wunsch und zeigt was
der rasch und so erfüllt
stefano lucchini hat eine neue
buchungsplattform für das hostel in kuba
eingerichtet als gelernter informatiker
ist dass sein ding
sein kollege übernimmt jetzt in kontakt
mit den kunden wenn das gut läuft wäre
es ein gelungener einstand in mexiko
so muss es richtig drin
die beiden wollen aber auch eigene
geschäfte machen land kaufen wohnungen
bauen an reiche ausländer verkaufen so
der plan
interessanter investoren und machte mit
uns aber ich glaube müssen sie natürlich
auch selbst umzüge vor ort.de um das
braucht alles eins bis drei
ist das denn wirklich konkret wird denn
ja so haben wir deine staley bis jetzt
wollen wir in der zwischenzeit doch eine
ausfindig machen wie funktioniert der
markt nicht funktioniert
beamte was muss ich als steuerzahler man
froh denn auch verstehen wie
funktioniert überhaupt das wissen ist in
mexiko und in boscheln liter über die
besichtigung im schnitt um trittin
[Musik]
regentage in schatz im kanton luzern bei
den schwiegereltern von markus wird das
abschiedsfest für die auswanderer
vorbereitet schwiegervater tee hilft mit
dem regen schutz
sie haben 40 leute eingeladen
freunde bekannte und silvias geschwister
im haus der schwiegereltern ist genügend
platz
die wohnung von silvia und markus ist zu
klein und voller zügel kartons theo hat
mühe damit seine tochter nicht mehr in
der nähe zu haben
der markus und sylvia arnold aus
geschäften für bis zu 70 cent
dass sie andere zukunftsplan handwerker
andere zusammen der mini damals
überrascht will diesen gegen walter berg
sehen also von dieter spürt man ja
eigentlich dass sie die richtige ist
schon heftig
brasilia theo konnte die firma
mittlerweile verkaufen an einen
mitarbeiter aber hinzunehmen dass
sevilla und markus sie nicht
weiterführen wollten fiel ihm und seiner
frau beatrice schwer
die 80 jährige hatte dort sehr gut wie
die firma aufziehen sonst gut gemacht
denn es sind jährlich zum glück
[Musik]
jetzt aber zählt nur noch ihr neues
zuhause in schweden und die freunde
freuen sich mit ihnen und ich haben es
ist ein klassisches krise schiffe und
mehr hoffe ich dass sie ruhiger was sich
verrückte doppel aber dass iran hatten
sie jede klasse unterwegs sie mir
wünsche dass ich wirklich alles
[Musik]
[Applaus]
noch einmal hoch hinaus bevor die
bordcrew riss und die kinder nach
südafrika aufbrechen haben sie ein
letztes mal die familie um sich
versammelt die eltern von doris und ihre
schwester mit mann und kindern vom kap
sohn john oberhalb von flims wandern sie
zur alten ganz klar
[Musik]
negativ sind
yahoo
[Musik]
laufen
folglich mir ins deutschschweizer schön
endlich gemerkt
schließlich verschaffte für richter
schließlich hatte ich viele unis und
langweilig
[Musik]
so einfach zusammen kommen das wird für
die familie bald nicht mehr gehen
[Musik]
und schon jetzt ist die wehmut groß
vor allem bei den großeltern
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
stefano tier und sein zimmer im haus
seiner eltern in zwei tagen geht der
flieger nach mexiko seine eigene wohnung
hat der 31 jährige schon vor monaten
aufgegeben mutter anita hilft packen
aber das ist jetzt möglich weiß dass es
sich nicht schöner schlüssel war sicher
nicht so einfach ein umzug nach vorn
aber es gebe bei mir das ein grund gibt
das buch ja nicht so viele hatten mich
stimmt und leid sagt gemacht
[Musik]
die beiden stefanos verlassen die heimat
ohne großes fest in den letzten wochen
haben sie sich schon nach und nach von
den freunden und kollegen verabschiedet
aber heute steht noch ein wichtiger
termin an
rockig geschäftspartner stefano muss mit
trotz erkältung
[Musik]
kontaktpflege ist angesagt networking
stefanova retters stärke
[Musik]
die beiden die sie besuchen sind alter
bekannter und könnten für mexiko wichtig
werden
[Musik]
pascal sie christ und claudio yanez hin
zu geld gekommen mit versicherungen und
handflächen die auswanderer hoffen dass
die beiden später bei ihnen investieren
zum abschied zaubert pascal noch
hochprozentiges aus seinem sportwagen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
bald geht es 1600 kilometer richtung
norden
markus und seebeben in war wie ihre
wohnung ein komisch wir gelacht werden
alles muss in den kleinen lkw passen den
umzug nach schweden organisieren die
brooks nur mit familie und freunden in
wenigen tagen haben sie die drei zimmer
wohnung an der bahnstrecke hinter sich
gelassen und wohnen in ihrem hof am see
auch wenn noch nicht alles perfekt ist
[Gelächter]
jetzt können sie endlich einziehen
der verkäufer hat sein okay gegeben
obwohl der handwechsel noch nicht im
grundbuch eingetragen ist besitzer ihres
hauses werden sie erst wenn das
grundstück in schweden neu vermessen ist
dass die möglichkeit hätte sie nicht
braucht es plötzlich
die schublade
die ruhe von späten ist zum greifen nah
[Musik]
in liestal sind nur mutter amelia und
ihr partner zum abschied gekommen
meister werden wollen
stefano ist am elias einziges kind unser
spezieller platz
[Musik]
mit der bahn reisen die jungs nach
kloten
die wirkung gehabt und was ist nur los
[Musik]
dann geht es nur mit ein paar koffern
über frankfurt weiter in die karibik
[Musik]
familie türkei fliegt in einer stunde
nach südafrika
so richtig eröffnung fertig
[Musik]
es ist eine reise ins ungewisse ans
andere ende der welt
rund 9000 kilometer immer richtung süden
[Musik]
und hebel die big five
ja
fröhliche tänze schönes liebenswertes
afrika
[Musik]
einige jahre dort gelebt das sind die
vier jahre weg zwischendrin immer
regelmäßig zurück haben dass sie sich
sehr verbreitung co
ja
red
die kraft
richtig wahnsinn
[Musik]
also geht doch
auf diesen tag haben die stephanus lange
hingearbeitet dass die erste nacht in
mexiko in der villa von stephanus onkel
[Musik]
fernando navarrete ist geschäftsmann
seit mehr als zehn jahren lebt der onkel
hier in kranken
perfekt alles gut alles ist wie wir
unser großes harz und dann bald das harz
gab verschiedene frauen sagen wir so
müller
[Musik]
so ist zu vermuten
mexiko mexiko
in der nächsten folge familie zogaj muss
ihre pläne mit der farm aufgeben
sie sind raus aus der langeweile
unerwartete stress
für die burg soll ein neues leben
beginnen
perfektes glück in schweden und in
mexiko muss defago in der firma gleich
ran wir hoffentlich vollmachtgebers ich
für ihn geschrieben
aber genau hier wollen die jungs geld
mit immobilien machen der stadtväter
sind auch die lücke
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und fonds